one of on monday one of the nation's
greatest monuments turns 100 the lincoln
memorial immortalizes our 16th president
and honors his role in saving the union
during a bloody civil war but while the
building was conceived as a shrine and a
temple it quickly took on another role
as the nation's premier backdrop for
demonstrations demanding social change
for a century it's been the backdrop of
monumental moments celebrations of our
democratic ideals
and promises to live up to them he stood
right here gave his speech on these
steps activist talik mcmillan echoed dr
martin luther king jr from 1963.
dr king spoke about the check that
bounced in the bank of justice he spoke
before marchers in 2020 after the
killing of george floyd giving that same
call for justice
um it was powerful
goose pimples i got goose pimples
from here all the way back
i couldn't see the end of where people
stopped at
and i had my mother sitting here
screaming you go you go it was it was a
powerful moment for nearly its entire
hundred year history this has been a
focal point for civil rights
demonstrations mike litterst guards the
national mall and has been a park ranger
for nearly 40 years the first documented
demonstration for civil rights takes
place here in 1926 just four years after
the memorial is dedicated and of course
after that comes marion anderson
[Music]
the world famous contralto was the first
black singer to perform at the memorial
the result of being denied the stage at
constitution hall because of her race
there is no justifiable reason
for discrimination
because of ancestry
or religion
or race
or color
in 1947 a sitting president harry s
truman welcomed the naacp from the
memorial steps in a show of support
events that seemed to capture lincoln's
own words from his gettysburg address
inscribed on the south chamber wall
this nation under god shall have a new
birth of freedom and that government of
the people by the people for the people
shall not perish from the earth but when
it was dedicated on may 30th 1922
the people didn't seem to include
everyone the visual
of that day
a day that's supposedly
commemorating this great emancipator if
you look out into the crowd
you see a segregated audience historian
erica armstrong dunbar says armed
soldiers kept black and white spectators
from mixing in the crowd and the lone
black speaker tuskegee institute
president robert moton was censored by
the lincoln memorial commission he was a
disciple of booker t washington
who was probably one of the most
well-known politicians at the black
politicians
educators of the time there was no room
at this moment
on memorial day
a holiday that really was created by
formerly enslaved people even still
dr moton wasn't allowed to
speak his truth his original speech
declared we erect a hollow mockery a
symbol of hypocrisy unless we together
can make real in our national life in
every state and in every section the
things for which he died neighboring
other symbols of power might and justice
this memorial stands immortalizing a man
many still seek to define there seems to
be a sentiment that we have to
remember our heroes as infallible why
have we glossed over the reality of who
lincoln was it doesn't
facilitate a beautiful image if we talk
about indecision or the fact that he was
unwilling at first to have black men
fight in the civil war the lincoln who
entered office
was not the lincoln who was eventually
assassinated in the theater by the time
we get to the theater he was someone who
had accepted
that slavery could not exist
that it would destroy continue to
destroy
the nation did he think that blacks and
whites were equal
i think there's room to debate
on that
and yet he remains larger than life you
see abraham lincoln seated there on that
chair 19 feet tall and the statue itself
reflects the sort of the duality of
abraham lincoln one half of him is
sitting pensively his hands on the chair
thinking
the other half he's a man of action his
arm is starting to move his foot is
lifted bringing out those two sides of
lincoln that were so well known a
monument amplifying voices
across class race gender and sexual
orientation
[Applause]
and some say an assignment for a new
generation i feel like we all have a
responsibility this is intergenerational
and whether it's speaking here in front
of hundreds of thousands of people or is
organizing people in your local
community we all play a crucial part in
moving this movement forward i think the
stronger point there is
that a hundred years after the end of
slavery
we could fast forward to 2022.
we're in the streets
still asking this question
about black life
does it matter in this nation
if it does why don't we see it why
doesn't it register a question that
still lingers and for the more than 8
million people who visit here each year
a place of reflection there is no place
quite like the lincoln memorial i think
it is the sense of calm and quiet in a
city that is constantly bustling the
respect and awe that people seem to have
when they enter that chamber and look up
at that enormous statue the way that the
memorial is illuminated and the still
and the quiet in that chamber it it's
almost a religious experience
and every time it gets me every single
time
oh it's amazing and just the way that
you know they talked about about them
way him sitting there and they see
sitting back and waiting you know
pensive and thinking but also ready
ready to act at the same time and i love
the point michelle about
our leaders were not infallible
and the way you have to look at lincoln
maybe with a different perspective and
understanding this was not a perfect man
and a man who was conflicted yeah
troubled and
you know it's just
it makes people more real yeah it makes
our heroes oh there's no doubt about it
great job